[Música]
en eeuu de la administración bailén se
mostró dispuesta a regresar al acuerdo
nuclear si teherán vuelve al estricto
cumplimiento de lo firmado en 2015 iran
contestó asegurando que es washington
quien debe dar el primer paso levantando
incondicional y eficazmente todas las
sanciones
la corte suprema de reino unido
dictaminó que uber debe clasificar a sus
conductores como trabajadores sino como
contratistas independientes con esta
decisión la empresa puede verse obligada
a otorgar derechos básicos tenemos
reportes de reino unido
hoy se celebran la cumbre del g7 y la
conferencia de seguridad de múnich ambos
eventos serán una oportunidad para que
el nuevo presidente estadounidense joe
biden demuestre un renovado con
prejuicio a sus socios europeos tras
cuatro años de donald trump la pandemia
el cambio climático la retoma del
crecimiento económico mundial y los
retos food and tea chinas serán temas en
la agenda
muy buen día gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 si raúl blanco
como siempre un gusto saludarlos
comenzamos con la propuesta del gobierno
del presidente de eeuu joe biden que
ofreció formalmente reiniciar las
negociaciones con irán sobre el acuerdo
nuclear el ex mandatario de donald trump
retiró al país en 2018 por su parte el
ministro de exteriores iraní mohamad
yavad sharif respondió que el primer
paso que tiene que dar eeuu es levantar
incondicional y eficazmente todas las
sanciones sin embargo washington expresó
que para levantar estas sanciones
teherán tiene que dejar de enriquecer
uranio y no limitar las inspecciones
internacionales a sus instalaciones
atómicas desde la capital iraní
nuestra corresponsal catalina gómez con
todos los detalles
ha sido el ministro de exteriores iraní
mohammad javad sheriff quien ha estado
en la delantera a responder los últimos
movimientos relacionados con el acuerdo
nuclear con irán dados tanto en
washington como las capitales europeas
en las últimas horas esto lo ha hecho a
través de varios trinos el último se
refirió al movimiento dado por el
gobierno estadounidense joe biden de
retirar esa petición hecha por el
gobierno anterior de donald trump verde
e imponer nuevas sanciones contra irán
en el marco del consejo de seguridad de
las naciones unidas aludiendo a un
mecanismo conocido como el snap back en
la resolución 22 31 que irán en su
momento había dicho que no era que no
tenía ninguna validez
sharif le dio la bienvenida pero dijo
que irán no volverá a comer cuando
firmado en el acuerdo hasta que eeuu
vuelva o quite todas esas sanciones
económicas que ha impuesto sobre irán
desde 2018 esto se da en un momento en
el cual la preocupación sobre el futuro
del acuerdo aumenta pues el próximo
martes se prohibirá el acceso relámpago
de los inspectores de la organización de
energía atómica a ésta
plantas nucleares lo que ha hecho que el
movimiento diplomático a nivel mundial
sea aún mayor para tratar de salvar este
acuerdo en otras noticias la empresa de
transporte uber perdió la batalla legal
que comenzó en 2016 y deberá clasificar
a sus conductores como empleados sino
como trabajadores autónomos así lo
determinó el tribunal supremo de reino
unido- este viernes el fallo de los
jueces concluyó que los empleados de la
compañía deben tener acceso a todos los
derechos básicos así como a vacaciones
pagadas conectamos con nuestra
corresponsal luisa pulido luisa cuáles
son las implicaciones de la decisión de
la corte suprema- tanto para reino unido
como para el resto de países donde
también se usa esta aplicación
a esta hora los conductores de uber en
el reino unido celebra en esta decisión
que ha sido considerada histórica en una
larga batalla judicial se estima que 45
mil conductores están vinculados a esta
plataforma aquí en el repetido las
implicaciones son varias primero para
uber la compañía directamente ahora que
tendrá que pagar derechos laborales a
sus empleados tendrá que considerar como
parte de la organización tendrá que
pagar las vacaciones el derecho a la
salud en caso de que se enfermen y otro
tipo de derechos laborales para los
consumidores seguramente el servicio de
uber aumentará y habría menos oferta lo
que ahora que son empleados directamente
contratados habían menos conductores
disponibles también tiene implicaciones
para la economía informal en el reino
unido uber no solamente presta el
servicio de transporte de pasajeros sino
también de domicilios y por supuesto
para las aplicaciones porque el modelo
de negocio se impactó directamente con
esta decisión y seguramente la decisión
judicial que se ha tomado hoy aquí en el
reino unido- motivará que conductores en
otras ciudades del mundo busquen este
tipo de derechos así es luisa gracias a
por toda la información que tenga usted
un félix resto de día y hoy se celebra
la cumbre del g7 en la conferencia de
seguridad de múnich ambos eventos en
formato virtual debido a la pandemia las
citas serán los primeros eventos
multilaterales con presencia de nuevo
líder de la casa blanca- joe biden se
espera que el presidente estadounidense
pida acción en términos de inversión
para impulsar la golpeada de economía
mundial se comprometa con 4 mil millones
de dólares para el mecanismo kóvacs y
reitera el rol de liderazgo de su nación
tras cuatro años de la política de
américa first del presidente del ex
presidente aún al trump informatice
muñoz
pandemia emergencia climática y nuevas
relaciones en la conferencia de
seguridad de múnich celebra una edición
especial en formato virtual servirá
especialmente para replantear la
relación transatlántica entre europa y
eeuu atrás
era de donald trump en el gobierno este
será el primer compromiso multilateral
con europa del presidente joe biden el
presidente hablará sobre la importancia
de nuestros lazos transatlánticos y la
necesidad de que estados unidos y europa
aborden retos globales juntos del iutet
si la nueva relación transatlántica
tiene como retos un liderazgo común
frente al auge de china también servirá
para establecer unidad en la relación
con rusia e incluso el jueves se supo
que la colaboración empieza a
fructificar eeuu está dispuesto a
reiniciar conversaciones con irán bajo
invitación de la unión europea creó en
la conferencia participarán también el
presidente de francia emmanuel macrón la
canciller alemana angela merkel y la
presidenta de la comisión europea
ursula von der leyen que tras la
posesión de bailén ya había celebrado el
regreso de eeuu al multilateralismo
europa está lista para un nuevo comienzo
con nuestro socio más antiguo y fiable
por eso la comisión adoptó recientemente
una nueva agenda trasatlántica con
visión de futuro
y el origen de la conferencia de múnich
se remonta a 1963 cuando alemania
estados unidos y los países de la otan
se comenzaron a reunir anualmente para
contrarrestar la fuerza de la unión
soviética
tras el encarcelamiento del rapero pablo
hasél en españa' el país suma a su
tercer día consecutivo de protestas que
terminan en choques violentos con la
policía el artista fue acusado y
condenado por prisión a prisión por el
enaltecimiento del terrorismo injurias a
la corona alba santana con todos los
detalles barricadas y protestas por
tercera noche consecutiva en varias
ciudades de españa tras la condena y
encarcelamiento del rapero pablo hasél
por enaltecimiento al terrorismo a
través de 'twitter' y por amenazas su
detención causó la indignación de miles
de ciudadanos que alegaron falta de
libertad de expresión con protestas que
terminaron en choques violentos con la
policía y que han provocado el arresto
de decenas de personas en todo el país
el suceso fue el detonante que
desencadenó la ira de los jóvenes
españoles con la tasa de desempleo más
alta de europa y números sólo por el
tema de que hay presos políticos sino
porque nos enfrentamos a una crisis
económica súper grande los jóvenes
estamos muy precarizado
tenemos las tasas de desempleo en las
que somos los primeros en europa y lo
dejas él ha sido un detonante
los mayores altercados fueron
registrados en barcelona donde una
ciudadana perdió un ojo a causa de un
disparo con una bala de goma el martes
por lo que se ha abierto una
investigación la tensión parece estar
escalando también en la esfera política
mientras el partido socialista guarda
silencio su otro socio de gobierno
podemos se posicionó el jueves a favor
del indulto de castle y pidió también el
de otro rapero exiliado
el indulto no solo lo hemos pedido para
hacer en coordinación con su abogado
diego el orden lo hemos hecho extensible
aval tonic en coordinación con su
abogado gonzalo boyé merecemos una
democracia sin raperos en prisión ni en
el exilio esto podría fracturar la
coalición de gobierno en españa entre el
partido socialista y podemos mientras el
país sigue sumido en manifestaciones
y en colombia al menos 6.400 dos
personas fueron víctimas de muertes
ilegalmente y legítimamente presentadas
o por el estado como bajas en combate
llamados 'falsos positivos' así lo
informó la jurisdicción especial para la
paz eso supone un aumento en casi tres
veces de las cifras de 'falsos
positivos' de la que se tenía
conocimiento hasta la fecha la gente
determinó que el 78 por ciento de la
victimización se produjo entre los años
2000 y 2008 durante la presidencia de
álvaro uribe vélez quien calificó el
informe como un intento de lage por
desacreditarlo para profundizar sobre
ese tema quiero saludar en este momento
a germán romero abogado defensor de
derechos humanos e integrante de the h
colombia organización que asume casos
graves de violaciones por agentes del
estado señor romero gracias por estar
aquí con nosotros en france 24 muy buen
día le pregunto porque hasta ahora se
conoce este sub registro que triplica la
cifra conocida por la fiscalía
es importante manifestar que este este
número o la intensidad de este fenómeno
criminal que realizó el ejército
nacional lo que aunque todavía cometen
ya las organizaciones de derechos
humanos y las organizaciones de víctimas
lo veníamos anunciando desde el año 2008
siempre se nos trató de mentirosos se
nos trató de decir que era un acto de
saboteo de hablar mal del gobierno
nacional y de las fuerzas militares para
nosotros es importante que hoy una
entidad del estado como la jurisdicción
especial para la paz haya hecho este
reconocimiento de la intensidad y el
número de víctimas que generó el
ejército nacional en una serie de
asesinatos donde todas las unidades más
de 200 batallones en 31 departamentos
están vinculados todas las divisiones
del ejército y que es absolutamente
necesario que la jurisdicción especial
para la paz de un paso no solamente en
identificar este universo de víctimas
sino en no repetir los errores de la
fiscalía o lo que ya hizo la fiscalía en
materia investigación sino que de forma
definitiva como lo preguntan las madres
de todos estos casos
que quien dio la orden y se pueda llegar
a sus responsabilidades es una situación
que es bien importante ahora y que
esperamos que la gente no haga y
continúe una investigación que no que no
pueda llegar a esa respuesta
germán y le pregunto qué responsabilidad
tiene el expresidente álvaro uribe y los
gobiernos posteriores
alvaro uribe velez no solamente era el
presidente juan manuel santos era el
ministro de defensa ellos conocían de
primera mano lo que venía ocurriendo con
el ejército nacional a ellos se les fue
avisando por parte de naciones unidas-
por parte de las organizaciones de
derechos humanos que pasaba en el
departamento de antioquia en la costa
carillo en los llanos orientales en el
sur occidente del país y ellos tienen
una responsabilidad que han querido
negar y es cómo fue que orientaron al
ejército nacional en que tuviera un
mensaje de ganar la guerra
nosotros tenemos casos donde
directamente la labor de inteligencia y
la presión que se ejerció sobre los
comandantes de las divisiones la hizo el
expresidente álvaro uribe vélez como en
caldas en el eje cafetero y donde
claramente él ordenaba y pedía que una
unidad que daba resultados es decir que
cometía este tipo de ejecuciones pasar a
departamentos donde se necesitaba
representar este tipo
germán gracias por su tiempo y por estar
aquí con nosotros en france 24 que tenga
usted un feliz resto de día a nosotros
nos vamos hasta perú país que ve
amenazada su famosa gastronomía debido a
la pandemia de ccoo y 19 las medidas de
restricción impuestas por las
autoridades están llevando a muchos de
ellos a la quiebra el informes de
nuestro corresponsal francisco zacarías
a sus 55 años el chef javier vargas
tiene 16 villerías y un respetable
prestigio
pero él teme que su comida nunca más
puede hacer degustada por sus clientes
con la nueva cuarentena que no permite
la atención del público sus restaurantes
se encuentran a punto de quebrar con
estas restricciones últimas del gobierno
lo que está haciendo es conducirnos a
una muerte anunciada' en los
restaurantes en el perú en medio de la
segunda ola que golpea perú las
autoridades ordenaron que los
restaurantes solo trabajen por la
modalidad del entrega a domicilio algo
que no es posible para el 75% de ellos
el gremio afirma que existen miles de
negocios gastronómicos que no pueden
sostener planilla ni cubrir sus costos
operativos en la situación crítica no de
los 200.000 restaurantes que había antes
de la pandemia ya 70 mil cerraron sus
puertas definitivamente eso hace que al
día de hoy más de medio millón de
personas hayan perdido su puesto de
trabajo directamente estamos hablando de
moxos cocineros gente de limpieza gente
que trabaja directamente los
restaurantes el gobierno peruano anunció
un fondo de más de 500 millones de
dólares
para que la micro y pequeñas empresas
más golpeadas por la pandemia no
colapsen estamos apoyando a las empresas
a las familias y vamos a apoyar a los
trabajadores para que este costo no sea
tan grande javier vargas considera que
la ayuda no es suficiente
[Música]
y le está organizando un cacerolazo
virtual con los chefs y cocineros del
perú para exigir al gobierno no permitir
que la gastronomía peruana muera por el
cob y 19 y esta manera llegamos al final
del informativo continua con nosotros
con día
[Música]
france24 en español sigue creciendo
desde